it's because men has dominated religion
within time over history and this is
also why many interpretations of a
religion or a patriarchal in their
interpretation so I do believe that it
is important I do believe that with the
spreading of female Imams it will help
creating a more and progressive
spiritual approach to the interpretation
my father he always he introduced me to
two scholars who have a feminist
spiritual approach to the understanding
and interpretation of Islam and and the
way he practiced Islam and the way he
defines his interpretation to me it's
it's a it's a feminist spiritual
approach Sharon Khan Khan's father is a
Syrian who fled political persecution in
his homeland
her mother is Finnish and came to
Denmark for work Sharon was born in
Denmark and knew from an early age she
wanted to establish a mosque her goal is
to present Islam's enlightened tenets to
counter the perception of Islam as a
violent faith today she's speaking with
students from the US the Maurya mosque
takes its name from the Virgin Mary a
figure she feels signifies religious
unity she and her fellow female Imams at
the mosque also see themselves as
unifiers they've overseen religious
services lectures weddings and divorces
she and her colleagues are followers of
Sufism and Islamic sect Sufism is being
practiced and defined very differently
Sufism can be defined as mysticism as
music as as
the dancing their wishes it could be
spiritual practices it could be a
specific Islamic theology to me Sufism
is understanding a theological subject
or understanding things at a deeper
level where you also listen to the heart
yes / Paterson is researching Islamic
feminism and worldwide efforts to
legitimize it after reading an article
about champagne con-con in one of
Denmark's major newspapers he asked her
to speak at his Institute the mosque
here is the first one in Scandinavia but
Islamic feminism feminism exists in the
whole world it's quite big and
especially Toronto California there are
very many cities in the u.s. that have
mixed gender mosques also ill btq
friendly mosques Islamic feminism is a
minority but it's a bigger minority than
jihadism in a Western context to counter
growing Islamophobia Shireen speaks
openly with international media outlets
she cites the teachings of learn at
Islamic mystics like eben Robby who
spoke about gender equality more than
800 years ago following this example
Sharon wants to empower women on Fridays
she offers prayer services for women
only women come to this mosque they
listen to the hood / they will go home
they will have discussions with their
husbands and so slowly you will change
the structure of the family so what
happens in the musgroves way beyond the
mosque it affects the feminist Sharon
con-con is convinced her efforts are
working that however slowly society is
beginning to change
you